former Vice President Joe Biden says he
will be more mindful of people's
personal space with seven women now
saying he touched them in a way that
made them feel uncomfortable one of them
former White House intern told The
Washington Post that Biden quote pressed
his forehead to my forehead in 2013
Biden who is expected to join the
Democratic presidential race posted a
Twitter video yesterday he essentially
said I get it and he said quote social
norms are changing I understand that and
I've heard that these what these women
are saying ed O'Keefe is here with more
on Biden statement and the reaction ed
good morning good morning guys it's good
to see ya the former vice president's
message comes after five days of
accusations and in the video he drops
his biggest hint yet that I'll have more
to say soon as a presidential candidate
the coming birth I expect to be talking
about a whole lot of issues and I'll
always be directly I get it
I hear what they're saying I understand
in the video Joe Biden acknowledged his
actions but did not apologize people's
personal space his comments come after
three more women told The Washington
Post Biden made them feel uncomfortable
one of those women Vail Kohner Tiant
said while she was a White House intern
in 2013
Biden pressed his forehead to hers she
remembers him telling her she was a
pretty girl
Caitlin Caruso met Biden after she spoke
at an event on sexual assault
all the women maintained what they
experienced was not sexual harassment or
assault but isn't behavior that should
be tolerated you're running for office
we're not grabbing people we're not
kissing them we're not you know hugging
them it just no on Wednesday Biden her
and support from an unlikely source he's
going to make his own decisions he's
very capable of making a decision but
the controversy has exposed a
generational rift among Democrats hold
you like that or something like that you
would call that sexual because the hell
you like this with the meeting
sometimes you're looking for with that I
think that we have a culture that finds
that acceptable and it's only recently
that we've started to discuss it Biden
is set to make his first public
appearance since the controversy
tomorrow in Washington at a labor union
event
you heard him hitting the video about
plans to speak out in the coming months
it's tell us he's still on course to
announce a campaign later this month at
the earliest and this story just
continues and now he's getting
criticized because he didn't exactly
apologize I guess I'm from the
generation if you're offering compassion
and empathy to someone who's told you a
sad story that that really is okay but
the bottom line or as you pointed out he
said he gets it but the whole thing I
just think is a very very sad
conversation to me that Joe Biden finds
himself in this place at this particular
time and is definitely sparked a
generational divide that we've seen this
you know you always remember the person
when you're ill or sick or someone in
your family that's died that comes to
your few your family members general or
calls you and that's not a lot of people
say about Joe Biden is that he's that
first person who calls and shows up at a
family member's funeral what makes this
hard as a political matter is that's his
core strength his empathy his fellow
feeling on the campaign trail despite
what the person the piece said
campaigning is a lot about hugging and
touching and reaching and doing all of
those healthy and connecting and that is
in his bones and so to TIA tell him that
the thing that's in his bones you can no
longer do yeah just make campaigning
harder so it'll be a Nancy Pelosi said
something interesting yesterday I know
we got to go Megan she said we should
all act like we have coals so we should
all just kiss each other yes at arm's
length what does that say that makes me
kind of made it I'm waiting for our
future I'm with you yeah Nothe by the
way today is hug and a local hugger news
person anchor you coming over in a
minute